this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description and get 20% off the annual
subscription 2018 was a rollercoaster
year for Apple in August its stock hit
two hundred and seven dollars making it
the first trillion-dollar company in
history then in a dramatic few months it
lost four hundred and fifty billion
dollars as Microsoft Amazon and alphabet
passed it by and for the first time in
15 years the company announced it would
make less money than expected the
problem fewer people buying iPhones the
reasons are many China's slowing economy
sticker shock market saturation but
there's also another big factor Apple
has a new competitor not Samsung not
Google not hallway Apple the iPhone is
increasingly competing with itself one
because we're all holding on to them
longer but also because it doesn't cost
what you think it does as the price of
an iPhone goes up something new is
happening to its value and it's shaking
up Apple's entire business model to
understand what's really going on we
need to calculate the actual hidden
price of the iPhone generally speaking
there are two ways you can get rich
selling things to people one you can
play the numbers game sell a gazillion
small things for a few cents profit each
think gas stations grocery stores and on
a good day Amazon sure you'll probably
lose money at first but sell a few more
and now you have the power of scale
lower costs higher margins look at you
or you can sell a few really expensive
things ever wondered why your town has
like three mattress stores for every one
person they're always empty and yet
somehow still keep the lights on well
that's because a few feet of foam
doesn't cost thousands or even hundreds
of dollars 50 60 90 percent of a
mattress is pure King
nice profit it only takes a few sales a
month to stay in business and therefore
disruption but a few companies the
really really successful ones managed to
do both if you can make hundreds of
dollars on each item sell it thousands
of times an hour and convinced those
same people to buy again in 12 months
and make us want to line up with a smile
on our face for the privilege of doing
it well now you have a 265 billion
dollar a year business the iPhone is
arguably the most successful
subscription service in history
you can bet Apple will announce a new
model or three every September like
clockwork just as surely as you know
they'll name it something weird the
problem is technology is getting really
good so good that a lot of people are
thinking why do I need a new one some of
us care about portrait mode and dual
optical image stabilization but for most
people checking Twitter and using WeChat
is the same on the iPhone 10s as the ten
and eight and seven you're invited to
the blue bubble Club regardless
according to analysts the average person
waited three years to upgrade their
smartphone in 2018 this year four of
course phones are a little bit weird in
this respect because so are humans the
iPhone isn't just a tool it's a status
symbol according to researchers at the
University of Chicago the best
predictors of wealth in 1992 were owning
an electric dishwasher a fireplace and
ooh a garage door opener high-tech today
it's owning a passport an iPhone and
iPad which have a 70% chance of
correctly guessing whether you have a
high income owning the newest model
signals you have a grand of disposable
income to spend every year
add some ear pods and you won't even
hear the sound of the money leaving your
bank account but that only works if this
year's iPhone looks different from last
and Apple only really changes its design
every other year so here we are people
are losing their appetite for frequent
upgrades but Apple certainly hasn't lost
appetite for money which means of course
higher prices selling half as many
phones isn't such a problem if they're
all twice as expensive the cheaper
iPhone has slowly crept from six hundred
forty nine dollars to six ninety nine to
seven forty nine today the more
expensive ten s now starts at $9.99 and
goes all the way up to one thousand four
hundred and forty nine dollars of course
that's only if you're lucky enough to
live in the US and yet revenue is still
down something's missing to make sense
of this we need to answer the question
how expensive is the iPhone really
there's plenty of back and forth on
whether the iPhone is quote worth it but
what isn't really debated is that in
general its higher price than most other
smart phones from most other brands
being selective about which price
segments it sells to is pretty much
written in Apple's DNA there's no 300
dollar MacBook not because it's
impossible but because that's just not
what it's about and with prices going up
even higher
it would seem that's never been more
true but sticker price isn't the best
way to measure actual cost in fact it's
pretty misleading phones aren't
consumable unless you pull a black
mirror there's still worth something in
a year or two the price of something
like a house accounts for how much it's
expected to gain or lose and value
usually the structure itself depreciates
styles change and wood rots but the land
underneath it appreciates which side
note is why tiny houses aren't
investments the land they sit on is
often least not owned and therefore it
only loses value basically you've just
bought a house shaped RV anyway unless
your phone was signed by the ghost of
Steve Jobs himself it's more like a car
it's value goes down and fast but not
all phones are the same on average
iPhones lose 45 percent of their value
in the first 12 months samsung phones 62
percent and Google 81 that may sound a
little
pher Apple only makes premium devices
while Samsung's average might be skewed
by a few low-end outliers so let's look
at specific models a year later the
Samsung sa lost 58 percent of its value
the Google pixel excel 82 and the
oneplus one 94% meanwhile the iPhone 8
still lost
only 45 that's a difference of hundreds
of dollars and that's before the
record-setting iPhone 10 in September
2018 only a week before the 10 s was set
to be announced the 10 was still worth
six hundred and seventy nine dollars it
lost only 32 percent of its value taking
this into account we can calculate a
rough total cost of ownership a thousand
dollars upfront - 679 for selling it a
year later
gives us a real cost of $320 that's $26
a month to always have the latest and
greatest now to be fair sticker price
does matter if next year's iPhone cost
twenty thousand dollars and sells twelve
months later for nineteen thousand nine
hundred dollars it would be a bit
disingenuous to call it a $100 phone but
of course resale value is still very
important and here's why because used
iPhones are now worth more more people
are selling them higher supply meanwhile
more people want the new design but
don't necessarily want to spend a whole
month's rent higher demand the result a
huge thriving secondary market Amazon
and eBay are flooded with iPhone tens
which means the new phone has to compete
with it's still pretty good last
generation in other words Apple is
increasingly competing with itself and
the better today's iPhone the harder
it'll be to compete against used next
year now if you're an investor this all
sounds pretty bad like sound the alarms
bad
remember the iPhone alone accounts for
60% of its revenue any other company
would fight this tooth and nail so
what's Apple doing not only are they not
fighting it they're actually embracing
it making the iPhone last even
longer instead of buying a whole new
phone because you can't get three hours
on a charge they've made it easier than
ever to just replace the battery and
while Android phones often receive only
two years of software updates iOS 12
runs on all these devices going all the
way back to the 2013 iPhone 5s and the
first iPad air even better it actually
speeds up your phone it's no longer a
trade-off of slow as molasses for new
features or let's be real pressing
update so it'll stop bothering you all
of this is awesome for you and I but
isn't it a terrible business idea not
necessarily unless you buy from
apple.com second-hand phones don't
directly put any money in its pockets
but Apple has other ways of making a
profit new or used you still buy apps
you still subscribe to Apple music Apple
video iCloud and so on the iPhone is a
gateway to things like the iPad Apple
watch and air pods even if you buy none
of these things you're still useful to
Apple Google for example pays an
estimated nine billion dollars a year
just to be your default search engine 9
billion that's the GDP of Haiti for one
switch to be flipped user base means
control and control ultimately means
money in other words things like
services can make up for lost sales it's
sort of the in-app purchase model
applied to the iPhone as a whole in the
long term Apple needs to move its focus
away from the iPhone and towards new
platforms entirely augmented reality
glasses are the future as we saw in 2018
this transition won't be easy but it's
the best and really only path forward
because the truth is what's happening
now is normal everything before was an
anomaly a very profitable one an easy
one for companies to get used to but
still an anomaly from 2007 until fairly
recently the stars were perfectly
aligned technology was moving incredibly
quickly but still always left enough to
be desired for next year the smartphone
was in its growth peer
but the average person buying a new
phone every year - just isn't
sustainable not economically and not
environmentally phones should last years
and years go through two or even three
owners and then gracefully be recycled
the future is one where a few of us buy
the latest phone take good care of it
and then give it back to Apple or sell
it secondhand the problem is selling
your phone is kind of the worst how do
you know when to sell and for how much
so it ends up just sitting in a drawer
somewhere Dave over at here's the bad
version has an idea for a solution an
app you'd scan your phone when you buy
it tell it how often you want to upgrade
and then it sends you a notification
when it's the best time to sell I'm 100%
serious when I say I think this could be
a multi-million dollar startup someone
just needs to program it you could
design the app to make predictions about
how the value of your phone might change
in the future for example with a machine
learning course on brilliant which
teaches you step by step intuitively
with its computer science and math
courses they're computer science
algorithms course will teach you the
concepts behind how you might design the
app to scan the iPhones barcode and then
generate an eBay listing when the user
is ready in my programming classes I
noticed I learned a lot faster when I
was actually making something versus
when I was just studying arbitrarily
plus it's just more fun to make
something brilliant thinks the same way
instead of here's this new concept now
stored in the back of your head it's
daily problems give you a real
interesting problem to solve using your
new skills use the link in the
description to sign up for free and get
started today the first 200 people to do
so will also get 20% off the annual
premium subscription so you can view all
the daily problems and take all their
problem solving courses and after you
sign up don't forget to go watch Dave's
video